everyone loves a good mystery and now
seems as good a time as ever to dive
into the mystery movie genre luckily
there are plenty of films out there just
begging to be discovered from perplexing
puzzles to harrowing whodunits here are
the best mysterious movies currently on
Netflix if there's one singular mystery
that's puzzled and terrified humankind
since the dawn of time it's this what
happens to us when we die unsurprisingly
this is a topic that cinema has
approached in all kinds of ways but few
of those movies have been brave enough
to tackle the mysteries of the afterlife
as directly as Charlie McDowell's the
discovery the movie is set in a not too
distant future where a scientist named
Thomas Harbor has proven conclusively
that the afterlife does indeed exist
unfortunately he doesn't know exactly
where or what it really is in the wake
of mass suicides by folks
eager to find out for themselves those
answers become more vital than ever
years after the discovery harbors deeply
skeptical son and an enigmatic young
woman arrived at the scientists research
compound and find the search for answers
has led to the invention of a device
designed to record the afterlife
experience from there the discovery only
gets weirder in the best possible way
the film uses its central mystery to
frame a beautifully textured and
grounded character studies steeped in
simmering small-scale dramas grand
theological commentary and a dash of
heart-wrenching romance it also happens
to be a first-rate slice of hard sci-fi
cinema adapted from a novel by Koji
Suzuki hideo nakata near-flawless j
horror the ring was so successful that
inevitable english-language remake soon
followed in 2002
gore verbinski brought his version of
the ring to theaters and in doing so
unleashed one of the greatest horror
movies of the modern era
these days the rings plot is practically
iconic just in case you're still in the
dark however the movie follows a
reporter who stumbles onto a perplexing
story about a videotape that kills
anyone who watches it seven days later
want to know more then go watch it
because this isn't a movie you want
spoiled for you here's one guarantee
though you'll never see the film's
shocking final moments coming and
there's a good chance you'll be haunted
by them for years to come for many films
the mystery is the whole point of the
story sometimes however it's merely a
tool used to set in motion a far more
ambitious narrative in the case of Trey
Edward Schultz tramatic thriller it
comes at night the movie's horrifying
mystery serves as the entry point for
several more small-scale dramas driven
by fear paranoia and a desperate need to
protect the things that matter most the
story unfolds in the aftermath of the
pandemic event that has wiped out untold
numbers of the world's population
more specifically the film follows a man
and his family riding things out in a
secluded cabin in the woods only to find
their rigorously structured life upended
by the arrival of another family as is
the case with many mystery movies you
probably don't want to know much more
than it's really best to enter it comes
at night with as little information as
possible just know that as the film's
minor mysteries begin to unravel a far
more grueling picture of humanity
unfolds within them those mysteries are
made all the more affecting thanks to
the steely low-key direction of
burgeoning auteur Schultz not to mention
a series of fantastic turns from the
cast including Christopher Abbott Riley
Keough Carmen ejogo and Joel Edgerton if
creepy mystery movies have taught us
anything over the years it's that people
should probably be wary of long lost
friends turning up at their door clearly
someone forgot to tell that to Jason
Bateman's character in the gift because
when Simon and his wife Robin bump into
his old high school chum Gordo they
immediately strike up an awkward kinship
with the man the plot thickens when
Gordo begins making uninvited
appearances in Simon and Robins lives
and starts offering them some
curiously head-scratching gifts with
each new encounter tensions between the
three begin to ratchet up all the more
and it's not immediately clear why fear
not however as all is eventually
revealed in the gift and it soon becomes
obvious that the murky past of one of
the film's characters is coming back to
haunt them beyond that you'll just have
to find out for yourself but this
devious revenge movie expertly directed
by star Joel Edgerton cuts deep into the
psyches of its lead characters and is
bound to leave you pondering the pivotal
mystery long after the credits roll one
of the key ingredients of any great
mystery story is the fear of the unknown
and the hugely unnerving small-scale
sci-fi drama freaks is positively
steeped in it in fact it's that
particular fear that drives not just the
film's overarching story but every
brazen twist and turn contained within
its narrative the story follows one
brave little girl who's been kept in
total seclusion from the world by her
increasingly paranoid father in the
aftermath of what's presumed to be some
sort of apocalyptic event as the story
unfolds however it becomes clear that
the world outside isn't exactly what the
father has made of it but that doesn't
mean that he's totally lying either
freaks is a puzzle box of a film the
pieces of which eventually form a
twisted picture that'll likely extend
far beyond your expectations as such
part of the fun of the film is watching
the brilliant ways in which the movie
carefully places each piece allowing the
mysteries of freaks to reveal themselves
at a pace that simultaneously slow
burning and brashley kinetic in a
perfect world the name Asgar ferati
would already carry the same sort of
weight and reverence as that of David
Fincher or Darren Aronofsky though his
name is highly regarded in the realm of
international cinema
ferrati hasn't found the same notoriety
with North American audiences just yet
with any luck however the directors
subtle it savagely tense thriller
everybody knows will change that
although everybody knows is a
spanish-language film
don't let the language barrier put you
off because this is very much a classic
kind of thriller 1sd
in long buried secrets and mysteries as
it is in true blooded pulse-pounding
thrills for much of the film ferrati
takes the slow burn approach using the
first 30 minutes to build an intricately
constructed house of cards around the
protagonists inter familial
relationships but these characters
worlds begin to crumble when a beloved
family member goes missing in the wake
of the disappearance deep dark secrets
begin to find the light and everybody
knows pivotal mystery begins to unfurl
with Shakespearean weight of course it
also helps that along the way Penelope
Cruz and Javier Bardem deliver two of
their finest performances to date and
that's saying something nothing suits a
mystery quite like a cult this has a lot
to do with the fact that the cult
mentality is as puzzling as the
enigmatic figures who front the cults
themselves though Justin Benson and
Aaron Moorhead's 2017 Lovecraftian
stunner the endless takes the enigmatic
leader mostly out of the equation their
film remains a no less sinister
psychological study of cults themselves
one that also happens to be driven by a
horrifying supernatural mystery and more
appealing trying to explain an
impossible color the endless follows a
pair of brothers who years after
breaking free from the alien death cult
with which they spent much of their
youth are called back into the fold by a
mysterious force as bizarre as it is the
endless is the sort of film that only
works if you enter its narrative with a
wholly blank slate
it also masterfully blends elements of
fantasy sci-fi and horror all without
relying on a high budget or a list
actors of course that didn't stop the
endless from attracting near universal
critical acclaim on its release go in
blind come out terrified by now you
should be well-acquainted with the name
jeremy song yeh if not there's no better
place to start than with the astonishing
one-two throat punch delivered by his
2013 and 2015 thrillers blue ruin and
green room once you've gotten caught up
on sanyas wildly original beyond tense
cinematic style stick around netflix for
a little longer and
treat yourself to the directors latest
beastly brooder hold the dark even
though it lacks some of the visceral
energy of his prior works hold the dark
is as accomplished a mystery film as any
other you'll find streaming set largely
among the gorgeous but unforgiving
vistas of the Alaskan wilderness hold
the dark follows famed Wolfe expert
Russell Corr who is called to an
isolated village after a six year old
boy is lost and presumed killed by a
pack of wolves once he arrives Kor finds
nothing is quite what it seems at the
town the case itself for the missing
boy's mother as Kor continues his
investigation saw me a twists hold the
dark from a basic missing person mystery
into a full-on heart of darkness style
metaphysical Odyssey complete with a
finale that will leave you baffled
breathless and broken in equal measure
if you're looking for a good
old-fashioned mystery movie that'll
tease your brain and raise your heart
rate at the same time you can always
look to the tried and true spy thriller
genre after all what could be better
than a story that's entirely built
around secrets in misdirection and if
its cold war intrigue year after then
look no further than Tomas Alfredson
immaculately executed adaptation of John
the car a spy novel Tinker Tailor
Soldier Spy if you're wondering why
alfred syns name might sound familiar
it's because prior to Tinker Tailor
Soldier Spy he previously directed
2008's pitch perfect vampire flick Let
The Right One In naturally Tinker Tailor
Soldier Spy and folds with the same
meticulous pacing and propulsive
menacing energy only this go-round
Alfredsson uses it to fuel a pitch-black
twist a minute thriller about the hunt
for a Russian agent embedded in mi6
leading the cast is an ever better Gary
Oldman who's surrounded by a veritable
who's who a british screen talent
including Tom Hardy Benedict Cumberbatch
Toby Jones John Hurt and Colin Firth
frankly if the thought of that
star-studded cast running down a spy
ring in the 1970s doesn't get you pumped
the mystery genre might not be for you
just saying as far as cinematic
subgenres Gote daytime horror continues
to be the one which most frequently
disturbs even the staunchest of genre
shinato's after all as unsettling as
horror movies can get when things go
bump in the night seeing those things
bump around in the light of day is often
twice as disturbing and although a few
notable additions have been made to the
daytime horror sub-genre of late the
gold standard remains the wicker man
no not that one this is Robin Hardy's
masterful 1973 thriller and as it
happens parties film is also a
near-flawless mystery movie whose unholy
secrets aren't revealed until it's
jaw-dropping final moments if you
haven't seen Hardy's original wicker man
for yourself the film follows a devout
detective who's dispatched to an
isolated Scottish island to track down a
missing girl when he arrives however the
townsfolk are quick to claim the girl
isn't missing because she never existed
in the first place from that central
mystery party weaves an intricately spun
web of intrigue that finds the detective
unknowingly playing fly to a
bloodthirsty spider to say more would be
to give the film away but suffice to say
that the film's portrayal of pagan
theology is downright terrifying and the
film's ending is the stuff of cinematic
legend check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more Lube
reveals about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]